no no
una asistencia notoriamente reducida y
con distancia social marcó el primer día
de la peregrinación a la meca
considerada uno de los cinco pilares del
islam
la peregrinación de este año está
ocurriendo en circunstancias
excepcionales por el coronavirus se
crearon nuevas medidas por primera vez
como la suscripción en línea a los pagos
y todo lo relacionado es bueno debería
repetirse y continuar para que sea mejor
en el futuro cercano es el segundo año
que la celebración se realiza bajo
estrictas medidas de seguridad a causa
de la pandemia de kobe 19 en esta
ocasión sólo 60.000 personas podrán
asistir
se trata de residentes de arabia saudita
que ya hayan sido vacunados que tengan
entre 18 y 65 años y que no presenten
enfermedades crónicas los participantes
fueron elegidos por sorteo de un total
de 558 mil aspirantes no puedo describir
lo que sentía al ser elegido no he
participado en el jai en 23 años y le
agradezco a dios que tuviera la fortuna
de ser elegido para ser parte de los
60.000 peregrinos
como parte de los controles tras bajar
de sus transportes se realiza una
verificación de la identidad de los
asistentes posteriormente se les entrega
una tarjeta inteligente con la que
pueden acceder a diversos lugares y
servicios habilitados de forma exclusiva
para el reino saudita la peregrinación
de este año supone uno de sus
principales retos luego de que en 2020
se realizará una versión en la que solo
pudieron participar 10.000 personas y al
final no se reportaron contagios